[Musica]
circa un anno fa ero a milano e che
lavoravo per uno studio ho ricevuto una
telefonata in cui mi si proponeva di
venire a lavorare per la fondazione
reggio children devo ammettere che la
prima cosa che ho chiesto è stata che
cosa avrei potuto fare io come
architetto per una fondazione che tratta
principalmente di ricerca
sull'educazione però per curiosità ho
accettato e ho avuto anche la fortuna di
essere preso e mi sono trovate inserite
in un team affiatato a girare in lungo
in largo per l'italia per portare avanti
un progetto il progetto fare scuola che
ha come obiettivo quello di fare ricerca
sui contesti di apprendimento in
contesti di apprendimento infatti ho
imparato ben presto che in questo luogo
sono estremamente importanti che
l'ambiente in cui avviene il processo
educativo è talmente tanto fondamentale
che viene addirittura definito il terzo
educatore e che questo era un pensiero
così tanto radicata all'interno della
fondazione per cui lavoro che aveva
deciso insieme ad enel cuore onlus di
iniziare un progetto che aveva
l'obiettivo di realizzare 60 interventi
mirati all'inter
all'interno di altrettante scuole sparse
per tutto il territorio nazionale
e se questo già non era difficile
cercava quelle scuole che erano in prima
linea nel trattare temi come l'abbandono
scolastico il disagio sociale all
illegalità ora che siamo arrivati un
buon punto perché nella piantina alle
mie spalle sono indicati i luoghi in cui
progetti sono già stati realizzati
lasciatemi però dire che la parte
probabilmente più interessante
sicuramente quella che è stata la più
faticosa è stato il processo con il
quale sono stati pensati rivolti in
volta i progetti architettonici e tutte
le attività che il progetto fare scuola
si è portato alle spalle infatti è stato
soltanto grazie al dialogo tra le scuole
ai comuni i pedagogisti e gli architetti
che è stato possibile costruire insieme
le idee che se che sono state poi dopo
realizzata e queste idee sono sempre
partite dal del territorio perché è il
territorio è il luogo in cui stando alle
scuole e con le quali le scuole si
interfacciano tutti i giorni ed è per
questo che abbiamo voluto chiamare oggi
con noi daniela che è una dirigente
scolastica del di una scuola del rione
sanità che come tutti i territori
coinvolti dal progetto anno affronta
tutti i giorni le proprie sfide nelle
proprie particolarità si il rione sanità
è un territorio come potete vedere anche
dalla foto la vostra sinistra quasi in
bianco e nero molte ombre e poche luci
è un territorio molto particolare e mi
ci sono ritrovata per puro caso
all'atto della scelta del mio primo
incarico da dirigente scolastico l'unica
sede è rimasta a napoli era nel rione
sanità una bella fortuna devo dire
passato il primo momento di
disorientamento
ho cominciato a viverlo questo quartiere
e mi sia attaccato addosso con tutta la
sua umanità con tutto il suo carico di
umanità ma anche con la sua spietata
ferocia in alcuni momenti nelle parole
dette ma soprattutto in quelle taciute
che cosa potevo fare io che non ero
figlia di quel quartiere ed ad inserirmi
in quel contesto e come poteva essere
riconosciuta da un dalla gente che entri
con che sentiva lo stato è l'istituzione
che io rappresentavo assolutamente
lontana dalla propria realtà è
cominciata quindi una nuova avventura ho
cominciato a girare il quartiere sono
scesa giù nelle viscere ho trovato degli
ipogei greci del iv secolo avanti cristo
sono andata nei cortili dei palazzi
settecenteschi linee venete 1 il palazzo
dello spagnolo sono palazzi di una
bellezza mozzafiato
ho trovato chiesa vanvitelliane tele di
luca giordano
ho attraversato 24 secoli di storia 24
secoli di storia
e lì mi sono chiesta come era possibile
che la gente che viveva in quel posto
che camminava in quelle strade non
riusciva quotidianamente più a vedere
quella stessa bellezza che io avevo
trovato ermanno rea nel suo ultimo
romanzo nostalgia scrive della sanità
c'era dolore in tanta caotica bellezza
c'era eccome
il dolore della fatica e dell'indigenza
ma era un dolore che lungi da almeno un
aree quella bellezza la esaltava fino
allo struggimento e questo era proprio
il punto quella bellezza era lontana la
gente non la percepiva più e quel
quartiere era diventato un quartiere in
bianco e nero e grigio e si colorava
solo con l'azzurro delle volanti e il
blu delle pattuglie quando scorreva
sangue nelle strade
e proprio vero diffondere speranza è
molto più complicato che cavalca le
paure però non è impossibile quindi ho
cominciato a pensare con me anche molti
dei suoi docenti mi sono sentita un po
come don chisciotte sun
avanza però sancho panza io ne avevo un
poco in più perché molti docenti
cominciavano a condividere questa mia
follia visionaria che ho cominciato a
pensare che c'era necessità di nuove
idee di gambe per portarvi avanti di
sguardi lunghi di motivazioni di alleati
convinti avevamo una congiuntura
particolarmente felice in quel momento
napoli aveva cambiato il sindaco e c'era
una nuova un nuovo assessore anna maria
palmeri una donna di scuola che
condivideva la mia stessa passione
visionaria e che come me guarda va oltre
e andava oltre la vista e andava verso
il cuore un giorno una mattina mi ha
chiamato e mi ha detto che reggio
children e nel cuore avevano deciso di
finanziare un progetto proprio al plesso
fontanelle quello più disagiato quello
più complicato quello meno ambito quello
che era proprio al centro dell'area
calda dove si svolgevano le stragi di
camorra con annamaria abbiamo condiviso
questa follia questa stessa follia
evidentemente era stata accolta anche da
reggio children e da enel cuore quindi
noi non potevamo fare altro che mettere
dentro le nostre motivazioni le nostre
emozioni
la nostra professionalità e tradurre
tutto in risorse e tra le risorse non
possiamo non citare anche la bellezza
infatti durante i vari sopralluoghi e le
visite che abbiamo fatto nelle scuole
abbiamo sempre cercato di capire con le
insegnanti che abbiamo incontrate con i
dirigenti scolastici quali fossero le
idee che già stavano mettendo in campo
per affrontare il cambiamento è con
questa consapevolezza abbiamo cercato di
creare all'interno delle scuole dei
luoghi che non fossero unicamente
funzionale ma che fossero anche belli e
alle mie spalle potete vedere un qualche
esempio infatti siamo convinti
che per chi vive la scuola tutti i
giorni e quindi per i bambini in primis
ma anche per i docenti e per i genitori
avere la possibilità di svolgere le
proprie attività all'interno di ambienti
piacevoli e gioiosi possa garantire loro
la forza e l'energia necessaria per fare
bene e per dare il meglio di sé
a marzo abbiamo organizzato qua in
questo luogo un evento di presentazione
per il progetto quando abbiamo
realizzato i primi trenta interventi in
quell'occasione stato donato ad ogni
partecipante un piccolo seme e questo
secondo me è la metafora perfetta di
quello che abbiamo voluto provare a fare
con con questo progetto infatti noi
siamo andati a realizzare tanti
piccolissimi all'interno delle scuole
sparse per tutta l'italia e siamo
convinti che se questi semi verranno
innaffiati da gli insegnanti potrà
crescere quel cambiamento che è sempre
più richiesto è necessario
nel nostro caso il cambiamento sta il
seme è stato molto fertile lo hanno
affidato nelle nostre mani poco esperte
devo dire in quel momento però siamo
stati supportati una maniera esemplare
da questo splendido gruppo di architetti
e di pedagogisti e così i bambini hanno
cominciato a riappropriarsi di spazi che
non erano fino ad allora utilizzati
proprio sull'esempio di quello che era
successo con il progetto reggio children
ed enel cuore il progetto ha
riqualificato un basta un vasto spazio
sia interno che esterno che non aveva
precedentemente un utilizzo efficace e
insieme a quella è stato è stata
riqualificata anche un'aula ed è stato
creato un atelier i bambini di
quell'aula quelli che occupano
quotidianamente quell'aula hanno subito
deciso di mettere a disposizione di
tutta la comunità scolastica i loro
spazi e poi sito si sono anche dati da
fare per aiutare i bambini della classe
attivo alla loro per ripensare anche
quello spazio e quindi capita che ci
sono ragazzi che utilizzano gli spazi
della scuola primaria ci sono docenti
che utilizzano grosse fette del bonus
premia nel famigerato bonus premiale per
acquistare materiali per la loro aula e
strutture nuove anche per proseguire in
questo cambiamento della didattica e
capita anche che i bambini della scuola
primaria alle 16 al suono della
campanella si lamentano perché non
vorrebbero tornare a casa vorrebbero
restare li vorrebbero restare lì a
curare quell angolo fiorito che hanno
creato nella loro classe e capita anche
come nel caso della foto che vedete una
foto un po scura però per me è molto
significativa di vedere ai ragazzi di
una classe della scuola secondaria la
classe più problematica forse di tutto
quel plesso che lavorano tranquilli al
piano luminoso per voi questo potrebbe
essere una fotografia di una classe
normale questi ragazzi non sono mai
presenti tutti quanti contemporaneamente
perché il nostro problema principale è
la frequenza a singhiozzo
sono ragazzi che hanno alle spalle
storie di abbandono di famiglia
disgregata e di genitori reclusi sono
storie che portano questi ragazzi ad un
minimo comun denominatore di una rabbia
esplosiva che in qualsiasi momento viene
fuori nei confronti della torta anche
per motivi banalissimi li vedete
lavorare in una maniera tranquilla
ma è serena probabilmente è stata una
delle poche volte quest'anno in cui
abbiamo visto verificarsi questa
evenienza e capita quindi che tutto
questo cambi e che si riesca a vedere il
cambiamento anche nella gratificazione
degli insegnanti che adesso verificano
che ad ogni loro insegnamento
quotidianamente corrisponde un
apprendimento e quella apprendimento
apre strade a nuove riflessioni a nuove
strategie e quindi si crea un flusso
ininterrotto di motivazione dalla tutto
al bambino e dal bambino all'adulto una
cosa inimmaginabile
da gennaio ad oggi questo è quello che
sta succedendo in quel plesso ea me
tornano sempre di più alla mente frasi
di docenti che qualche anno fa ormai ero
all'inizio della mia carriera da
dirigente
decisi di venire qui a vedere come
funzionava come funzionavano le scuole a
reggio e molti di loro cercavano forse
temevano il mio cambiamento o almeno la
spinta a cambiare cercavano di
convincermi che questo sistema poteva
funzionare solo qui adesso è una
soddisfazione poter dimostrare in
maniera incontrovertibile che tutto
questo può succedere che niente è
impossibile che tutto può cambiare ma in
certi territori addirittura deve
cambiare perché ce lo ha detto eduardo
de filippo nel sindaco del rione sanità
se ci trattate da erba cattiva
diventiamo sempre più cattivi quindi noi
dobbiamo aprire le porte alla speranza
di un cambiamento ma dobbiamo essere
convinti del fatto che il cambiamento ci
deve vedere tutti quanti protagonisti e
quindi dobbiamo impedire che una
profezia si auto avveri
dobbiamo imparare di nuovo a vedere
tutto a colori e dobbiamo dare alla
bellezza
la speranza del nostro cambiamento
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]